el objetivo central del sistema
inmunitario es mantener fuera de nuestro
cuerpo las cosas que parecen sospechosas
y si llegan a entrar entonces matarlas y
entre estas cosas se incluyen proteínas
sospechosas que puedan hacer daño a tu
cuerpo virus bacterias e incluso
parásitos eucariotas u hongos toda clase
de cosas que si entran a tu cuerpo te
causarían algún tipo de enfermedad
colectivamente se les conoce como
patógenos el objetivo más importante del
sistema inmunitario es en una primera
línea de defensa mantener estos
patógenos fuera y si entraran al cuerpo
entonces matarlos y eliminarlos de
nuestro sistema para que no nos
enfermemos ni muramos
así que ya mencionamos que hay dos
líneas de defensa incluso en ellas hay
algunas subdivisiones el papel de la
primera línea de defensa es mantener a
los patógenos fuera del cuerpo y hay
algunas obvias por ejemplo tenemos a la
piel la piel mantiene a los patógenos
fuera del cuerpo y también los aceites
en nuestra piel que son un poco más
ácidos lo que hace difícil que ciertas
bacterias prosperen en ese tipo de
ambiente también tenemos nuestras
membranas mucosas y las mucosidades
donde hay ciertos químicos que tal vez
dificultan un poco la supervivencia de
las bacterias y luego incluso tenemos
ambientes ácidos como el ácido estomacal
es probable que no veamos al estómago
como parte de nuestro exterior pero de
cierta manera si lo es tu tracto
digestivo completo y en un futuro
haremos vídeos sobre este tema realmente
está en tu exterior puedes simplemente
imaginar todos los cuerpos de los
vertebrados como una
donde nuestro sistema digestivo es el
centro de la zona si lo pensamos de esa
forma el ácido estomacal está en el
exterior de nuestro cuerpo y podemos
imaginar que este es un ambiente muy
difícil para que muchos de estos
patógenos sobrevivan
entonces esta es la primera línea de
defensa pero sabemos que esto no es
suficiente hay veces que los patógenos
ingresan a nuestro cuerpo y entonces
tenemos que empezar a pensar en la
segunda línea de defensa que hacemos una
vez que estas cosas están dentro de
nuestro cuerpo tanto en la primera como
la segunda línea de defensa hablamos del
sistema inmunitario no específico y eso
tendrá mucho sentido cuando empecemos a
hablar de inmunidad específica entonces
ambas líneas de defensa son no
específicas o innatas y cuando decimos
no específicas significa que responden
de alguna manera a cualquier cosa que
parece mala no recuerdan las cosas malas
que vinieron antes responden a cualquier
tipo de virus oa cualquier tipo de
bacteria es decir no dice me eres un
virus tipo
ps o eres una bacteria tipo a bs solo
dicen este es un virus déjame deshacerme
de él no lo dejaremos entrar esta es una
bacteria déjame deshacerme de ella no la
dejaremos entrar ellos no saben con qué
tipo de bacteria están tratando así que
recuerda hablamos del sistema
inmunitario no específico o innato y
vamos a entrar en muchos detalles sobre
el sistema inmunitario específico en los
siguientes vídeos pero podemos imaginar
que es un proceso muy interesante cuando
empezamos a pensar en que tu cuerpo de
alguna forma recuerda un virus que vio
anteriormente y es capaz de responder de
mejor manera a ese virus a esa bacteria
oa esa proteína la segunda vez que lo ve
pero ahora trabajamos con el sistema
inmunitario no específico y su segunda
línea de defensa tiene dos cosas
tiene la respuesta inflamatoria y voy a
hacer un vídeo entero de esto pero en
general todos hemos experimentado una
respuesta inflamatoria cuando vemos
sangre que influye a cierta parte de un
área de tu cuerpo y hay pus y llega
sangre con células que pueden pelear con
cualquier tipo de patógeno que tengamos
en el sitio donde nos cortamos la
respuesta inflamatoria consiste en traer
un líquido y guerreros a la pelea
como consecuencia parte de tu tejido o
parte de tu cuerpo se inflama hay mucho
fluido y muchos subproductos de la pelea
que están allí y la otra segunda línea
de defensa que es parte de la respuesta
inflamatoria es la fagocitosis o los
fagocitos lo que quiero que hagamos en
el resto del vídeo es hablar con más
detalle de los fagocitos para que
entendamos qué es lo que hacen porque
esto es una muy buena base para entender
el sistema inmunitario específico
también nos ayudará a llegar al tema de
la respuesta inflamatoria ya que los
fagocitos son parte de esa respuesta los
fagocitos son una clase de células que
pueden comer patógenos ellos pueden
comer otras cosas pero como hablamos del
sistema inmunitario nos interesan los
patógenos así que imagina que este es un
favorcito este es un núcleo aunque no es
tan importante enfocarnos en el interior
y todo por ahora y esta es una célula
eucariota tradicional pero lo que vamos
a observar es lo que pasa cuando el
fagocitó se encuentra con una partícula
o una bacteria extraña así que dibujemos
la esta es nuestra bacteria extraña como
mencionamos el favorcito es no
específico lo que hace que tiene
receptores que puedan responder a cosas
que simplemente saben que son malas
puedes imaginarlo como super sensores
así que aquí tenemos sus super sensores
tal vez lo sean para las bacterias y las
bacterias tienen proteínas en sus
superficies que tal vez se vean así
bueno seguramente no se ven así tal cual
pero la idea es que encajan como una ley
y un triángulo y una vez que están
conectados estos dos vamos a dibujarlo
este es el patógeno es decir la bacteria
pero lo mismo sucede con un virus o
cualquier otra cosa
y vamos a ver en otros vídeos que estas
cosas pueden ser etiquetadas por otras
moléculas lo que hace que estos
fagocitos quieran atacar aún más al
patógeno y esta unión activa el receptor
del favorito entonces él fagocitó
empezará a ingerir al patógeno empezar a
envolver al patógeno de esta forma de
tal forma que estos dos extremos se van
a tocar por acá tenemos al núcleo y
también tenemos a los demás organelos
pero una vez que estos dos extremos se
toquen como se va a ver de repente la
bacteria quedará completamente ingerida
estará dentro de la célula una vez que
los extremos se tocan estas membranas se
empiezan a unir entonces este patógeno
quedará atrapado en su propia burbuja
membranosa o podemos decir que quedará
atrapado en su propia vesícula tenemos
al patógeno en este caso la bacteria
pero este proceso de la fagocitosis
completamente idénticos tuviéramos un
virus o algún otro tipo de proteína o
molécula extraña incluso esto no sólo
ocurre con cosas extrañas puede ocurrir
con muchas moléculas viejas que no son
extrañas pero que necesitan ser
eliminadas
esta vez nos enfocaremos en el sistema
inmunitario
así que pensaremos solo en las cosas
extrañas entonces esta membrana de aquí
rodea al patógeno de esta forma y claro
por acá tenemos los receptores bueno
quién sabe si siguen allí
pero los dibujaremos para que quede
claro que esta parte es esta otra y una
vez que esté envuelto por completo esta
cosa se llamará el fago soma que
realmente es una vesícula que contiene a
esta partícula extraña de la que
queremos deshacernos y después llegarán
otras vesículas que contienen enzimas
que pueden comerse el fago soma es decir
por acá tenemos una vesícula que
contiene lisozima que contienen cosas
que son especies muy
de oxígeno entonces tienen cosas muy
reactivas por aquí que si se ponen en
contacto con cualquier compuesto
biológico le generarán un gran daño
entonces una vez que el patógeno está
completamente dentro de la célula llegar
a este pequeño paquete y se fusionará
para verter su contenido dentro del fago
soma dentro de esta vesícula que
contiene el patógeno y después lo
deshará básicamente lo digiere así que
la primera tarea es básicamente quitarlo
del camino y matarlo mientras que la
segunda tarea aunque sólo vamos a dar un
adelanto esta vez pero lo haremos a
mayor profundidad en los siguientes
vídeos será que él lo descompone vamos a
dibujarlo tenemos la membrana y lo
descomponen en proteínas constituyentes
y también otras moléculas y entonces lo
que el favorcito hace es tomar un
subconjunto de estas moléculas un
subconjunto de las proteínas recuerde
una proteína solo es una secuencia de
aminoácidos así que normalmente cuando
las personas hablan de proteínas se
refieren a cadenas largas de aminoácidos
y cuando las personas hablan de cadenas
cortas de aminoácidos o se hablan de las
partes de una proteína se refieren a las
cadenas peptídicas una cadena pep típica
es una cadena más corta de aminoácidos
así que este tipo va a tomar algunas
cadenas peptídicas algunas piezas de las
cosas que mató las adjunta a otras
proteínas vamos a decir que toma una
pequeña pieza de esta bacteria lo
adjunta a una proteína cuyo nombre es
complejo mayor de histocompatibilidad
que se abrevia como cnh y si hablamos de
fagocitos este será un complejo mayor de
histocompatibilidad tipo 2 y sé que esto
se parece un poco a un trabalenguas ah
pero vamos a trabajar mucho esta idea
y esta es una proteína que se une con
estos péptidos que recordemos provienen
de los fragmentos o de las partes
digeridas de este invasor una vez que se
une la proteína
con el péptido se presenta en la
membrana del fagocitó y la razón del
porqué explicamos todo este proceso ya
que estoy seguro que seguramente piensas
bueno ya nos deshicimos de este patógeno
y lo matamos eso es todo porque sal se
preocupa sobre los péptidos y todas esas
cosas pero la razón es que esto es
crucial para nuestro sistema inmunitario
ya que vamos a ver otras partes de
nuestro sistema inmunitario
recordemos hasta que hablamos del
sistema inmunitario no específico es
decir este fagocitó dice este es un
invasor no sé de qué tipo pero voy a
unirlo a mí y matarlo así que lo matan
pero ahora deja un resto de él en su
superficie y ahora las partes
específicas las partes que de hecho
tienen memoria y atacan cosas
específicas dicen
señor fagocitó mira tú mataste algo así
que déjame ver si existen algunas
reacciones específicas que puedan ser
desencadenadas por esta cosa que estás
presentando es por ello que muchos
fagocitos se les conoce como células
presentadoras de antígeno
hablaremos con más exactitud sobre qué
es un antígeno por ahora ya sabemos que
esto es un patógeno pero un antígeno lo
podemos entender como una proteína o una
cadena peptídica que desencadenará o que
puede ser manejada por el sistema
inmunitario no específico entonces esta
célula presenta un antígeno en su
superficie que después podrá ser
utilizada por otras partes ahora hay
muchos tipos distintos de fagocitos así
que haré una pequeña lista de ellos por
aquí espero no te confundas con tantas
palabras nuevas por ahora primero
tenemos los neutrófilos que son los
fagocitos más comunes y también son las
células que responden más rápido es
decir llegan al lugar de la infección
muy rápido entonces son rápidos y
abundantes
ahora los fagocitos no forzosamente
deben de matar de esta forma es decir se
llaman fagocitos ya que ingieren de esta
manera pero en vídeos futuros hablaremos
de otras formas en que liberan químicos
o incluso redes de adn
otros favoritos son los macrófagos de
cierta forma son los más versátiles y
hacen el trabajo pesado pero también son
fagocitos también tenemos a las células
dentríticas la primera vez que vemos el
término célula dendrítica pensamos que
temen de estar relacionadas a las
dendritas del sistema nervioso sin
embargo no forman parte del sistema
nervioso se les llama dendríticas porque
parecen tener dendritas es decir se ven
algo así de ellas salen unas cosas como
éstas algo así parecen neuronas en
cierta forma pero no participan en el
sistema nervioso de ninguna manera no
tienen nada que ver
estas tienden a ser los mejores
activadores del sistema inmunitario
específico del que hablaremos en los
siguientes vídeos
por ahora me despido pero seguiremos con
este tema en los siguientes vídeos